you're gonna have a good time tonight
[Music]
okay
[Music]
two
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you're never gonna finish
[Music]
this your is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to moses and
friends i am your host moses storm this
is the show where we take all of our
favorite people from the conan show
some of my friends check in with them
see how they're doing it's essentially a
podcast with really bad
zoom quality audio uh i hope you're
having a good week
i am i got to do my first real show this
week
for like real people um still not a real
show you stand in the back of a flatbed
truck
because of the way that city permits
work and you yell at strangers below
um which is fine it's like really fun
but
it's not a great look for me to be
yelling at a
group of people from a flatbed truck
like this head
this like don't you know who my father
is had it just
it looked like a hate rally so um i'm
part of
several alt-right groups now
my first guest you know him from his
comedy central special he's got a sketch
special with kami central with the
sombinage
called goat face please welcome the very
funny faheem anwar
how are you thank you hold for applause
hold on
talk about your career
i know hey how do we survive in this
coped world in these uncertain times
moses
i don't know it seems like you kind of
knew how to pivot immediately you you do
a lot of online videos
yeah kind of like uh i think he was a
comedian too it's like stand-up is our
main jam
and then we have these other outlets
like all right i'll do a dumb thing on
instagram or i'll do a tweet and
once the stage is gone i guess you just
kind of lean into what's still available
yeah because the stage i think it's
still kind of works if you're a
one-liner guy but i think you
and i i mean you on a much higher level
are very
physical performers a lot of it is like
in your body which you can't really do
totally and it's a conversation with the
audience so it's like if they're really
liking something
that informs you go oh let me milk this
so it's this song and dance with an
audience and that kind of informs your
act
so when you strip an audience away
you're kind of creating in a vacuum and
that's tough for
a stand-up live performer yeah cause
like a musician where you just play your
three-minute song
stand up if you're doing it right when
you get beyond like out of your head and
you're
doing it long enough you're essentially
asking the audience for permission
every 15 seconds or so can i keep
yeah so you've seen my new stuff yeah
i've seen it
um i had an hour it was about to come
out we were about to take it was gonna
be called
my dick sucks and we had like msg
we had that rent out it was gonna be
three nights
yeah my dick sucks and that's not my big
catch phrase oh my god
but now it's like on hold oh and then
you had you had a merch already printed
out
yeah i have so many boxes of my dick
sucks and i don't know where to put it i
have some of it in my place right now
and
it's not going to make sense when things
open up and my my
my dick is getting better you know i
think it's getting better it's not even
true anymore
it's not it's a false narrative it's
completely healed
since the accident totally i mean it is
a
there's some very sad options like i was
talking about top i mean you could
perform it about
you did the truck show huh yeah it's the
best version i heard it's good
i got asked to do it but i was i think i
was in denver for that weekend or
whatever but i hear it's great oh yeah
you were uh
you were in a covid's fake protest in
denver forgot about it yeah yeah
no i did some charity gig i did some
like charity gig and it was in a
it was an airplane hangar and they were
all in tuxedos it was just like upper
crust
denver i swear to god it's like i was
doing stand-up in a bond movie
insane at the airport i don't know all
the hell gigs are things that we're
essentially competing for it now like
yeah absolutely airport hangout who
books that
like the tallest ceilings like you know
the best thing for comedy is like in a
basement
low ceilings packed together this was a
hanger
just like the the voice just evaporates
they're sitting so far away from each
other
but they said they were still happy yeah
it's like what what can you do
sometimes i think about stand-up comedy
in the in yesteryear that we were just
a distraction to shovel food and drinks
into people's mouths yes
like we were there to keep them in the
seats long enough to
pull up a dump truck and put it in their
mouths yeah people wonder like what
why why do you do 45 to an hour of
material because that's how long it
takes to order
a drink some food and then another yeah
that's that's what this art form is no
painting
if you know that i'm like yeah totally
and
i love how nimble this art form is too
where like
if they're a little late to putting the
checks out on the table
they'll tell you to like they'll go like
this you know like go along
stretch it out and then you just you
know do some more [ __ ] for 10 more
minutes until everyone
signs their checks nothing else you
couldn't do that like with a magician be
like
more magic more cards just
get more energy more decks just the
magicians just vamping just
trying to make some tricks on the fly
yeah that's why i feel like
oh it was cringe when people make the
argument like let me say this is free
speech and it's like it's really
it's chicken wing speech it's just long
enough
the thing is i think there is that free
speech thing and you should be able to
but it's up to you to jump over the
hurdle of making it
funny for the room if like people are
turned off all the time you haven't done
the work
yeah the real trick in the beauty of
stand-up is taking that controversial
idea or whatever your idea is
and doing the gymnastics and massaging
it enough
where it's it's digestible for even
someone who has a posing view
like bill burr will do that all the time
and it's great like
they earn the laugh you can still get
your idea across you just got to do the
work
instead of like free speech man you
don't like it
people confuse just bombing with people
that like free speech
yeah like you didn't your writing wasn't
good enough don't pretend you're bill
hicks or something
right i don't need structure i'm
screaming about or
they don't get it like you're part of
the problem no just
right right a little more if you're
doing your job they should get it they
should get it i didn't like it
so does everyone in your life know that
you have all this time off you're not
performing on stage like are your
parents being like hey why are you
living
out there do you want to come home i
have this thought like uh
you get a sense of how much your parents
really believe in you
by how quickly they tell you to get into
real estate
you know what i mean to like start
selling houses yeah
like for me it was like a few days like
corona yeah the shutdown
like a week later like you should sell
houses like oh you never believed in me
like i'm finding out now and i always
like how that's the solution for
like parents everywhere is just like if
your kid was like kind of a [ __ ] up to
begin with
they're going to kill it in the real
estate market like suddenly they're
going to be
awesome if someone can't be a comedian
and monster that could work for 15
minutes a night and post some instagram
clips
one of the odds are gonna be free on a
sunday for an open house
sure you think they're gonna be on
selling sunset like hey thanks mom and
dad i was spinning my wheels with this
art stuff but now i'm a world-class real
estate agent
i'd love to show you some properties
like he's probably gonna suck at that
too
right there's no way the women are
selling cents that are actually selling
those properties
i wouldn't buy a house after that very
quick walk through where they're also
having
a huge fight i'm like well that's the
house for me
yeah i don't know like they all look the
same like do you have to be gorgeous to
sell houses
i think in la if you're selling that
because it's gonna be like just
so i wanna show you some properties
there's um there's one on mulholland
it's it's got this open floor plan
you're gonna love it
all right and are you take my card take
my card you know talk it over with your
wife you don't want to make a rash
decision i'm not trying to pressure you
but
i'm one of the best and you live in this
area well i do mostly stuff in
torrance but they gave me a shot at the
big time here on sunset one of the one
of the women from the show
you know one of the you know they're
busy they're busy right now that's why
they sent me to show you the property
um it's the same property it's just a
different person showing it to you
my ford focus i got to put money in the
meter real quick um i'll be back
he's at the bottom of sunset all the way
down the hill
can you give me a ride to my car i've
got to put money in my meter for my ford
focus
soaking wet dude that's what i noticed
too like if you're a real estate agent
you have to
even if you're not doing well you have
to lease a bomb-ass car
it's all exuding this even if you're
really good at what you do
you can't drive like a honda fit yeah
you got to show up because you're
selling an image and a lifestyle and
you're like yeah i want my guy to be
cutthroat
right you need to make people feel like
[ __ ] about their
life or just like oh man this guy he
deals with high society or i'm i'm
visiting
this world or he's gonna get me the best
like you don't want a practical
like you do but you want the fantasy of
this armani suit
lamborghini real estate agent not the
hell that i live in
showing up in it honda yeah you're like
this guy looks like
me i could just go on redfin
right this guy's like a brokerage deal
for me he came and cleaned his empty
gatorade bottles out of his car
there's no way i love them you ever
taken an uber ride where they go like
yeah just like shove it over yeah just
push it over yeah
hey you had one job like you're not my
friend
doing me a solid this is a transaction
like hey just push those rollerblades
over
[Music]
hey commit to the job so it's a
spaghetti
just filled back there well what i love
about taxi drivers is like they knew
they were a taxi driver
they accept they're like yes i drive
people around and you know like this is
my life i like doing it
and there was a clear distinction but
people ubering and lyft sometimes
they're in denial they're like yeah i'm
just doing this for a few weeks until
yeah just shove it over they gotta tell
you that immediately that this isn't
their job
no other job is like this isn't my job
by the way which is not reassuring when
someone's in charge of your
life you're up in a helicopter like
listen this is just my side gig
my real passion is children's modeling
just so you know i i don't enjoy doing
this
but where are you headed to
i am i am one foot out the door i'm not
even here for this job i miss like
because
because with the stars you know how you
rate each other everyone's on the best
behavior because you can still
be affected there's a beauty to taking a
taxi you can like clip your toenails in
the back
and there's no repercussions whatsoever
it'll never come back to you you may be
paying a premium
but you can be like you know [ __ ] your
mother yeah what are you going to do
about it and like
you have no stars to be yeah that's what
you like to do you're in the back seat
rock yeah no it's not a sexual thing
it's more of a power dominance thing
i just berate them and i clip my
toenails and i go what are you gonna do
you can't rape me thumbnails don't even
need to be clipped you're just like
really down to the bone yeah yeah you
look great man
i feel like look this isn't the most
high-res but i feel like you have great
skin
yeah there's several filters on this
yeah remember when
michael jackson would get interviewed he
would have his own lighting team to look
like a human
like when martin beshear was doing like
that documentary or whatever
yeah they showed this set like they had
several scientists
bouncing lights to to make it look
like a human face just bro like
yeah like i love mj but it was so funny
to think like
you know it had been carved up so much
that he needs this
the lighting like this so that the
shadows can kind of
fill in for the gaps yeah it always
looked like a gas leak was happening
like the air is
about to waving out yeah martin
beshear's like
michael um in the 80s
all right can i do it like a quick dance
just for my fans real quick
yeah it's what they tune in for do the
full thing
it's great that the whole apartment
shakes when you dance well you're on a
sofa so
and we are we are in la so there are
earthquakes we had one a few weeks ago
very important very important that we
stay here while it burns
and it's on fire and there's no
opportunities here but hey quippy could
be around the corner come on quibby
i need that quibby cash this section of
my house is on fire but i will not leave
yeah until i get a fitting for quirby
yeah man it's worth it
all right so people can find you if
anwar you're been on the joe rogan
podcast a couple times a lot of people
think from that and then um
uh your podcast you guys started back up
again called dance
yeah man or dance hour so that's on
spotify apple all that stuff
and then i'm on instagram at the
ximenwar um oh yeah my special my one
hour special it's free on youtube comedy
central put it out
it's called there's no business like
show business so
check out a free hour of stand up well
thank you so much man for talking to me
yeah man it was good seeing you and it's
cool to do something during all this you
know i know it's nice to have a thing to
do
i'll see you in a parking lot hey i'll
see you on the circuit
i'll see you on the circuit there are
the hot circuit of
people yeah all right emanuel everyone
peace my next guest has multiple
specials
on netflix of course you've seen him on
conan please welcome all the way from
india verdas fierce thank you so much
for for being here
you know with that it was no effort at
all i walked six feet
from from the bedroom over to this chair
and and i'm happy to be here
it's the easiest hat on yeah
no work went into this not at all right
i am not wearing underwear
there's i haven't had a haircut in six
months and this is uh yeah
it's pretty easy are you growing the
hair out i've been growing up i'm in
that awkward like i just have like uh
it's like emo face right now i've seen
i'm in the
uh i think yeah i think i hate my
parents but i don't know like i'm in
that phase right now
so yeah yeah we don't we still
desperately depend on them but
we hate them i listen to five indie
bands and you don't know any of them
that's the haircut basically we're like
their first stop
yeah whenever the first thing was we
haven't heard it because our parents
won't let us but
you you saying did you go through an emo
phase
outside of the big emo phase that the
world is going through right now no
yeah yeah outside of this
six billion people existential crisis
that we live in right now
no it's been all right like i was
telling someone i think
comedians especially like those of us
who spend a lot of time on the road
we're pretty well trained for a lockdown
aren't we like we just
you know we're in our hotel all day we
come out for an hour
and even then we don't like the people
we meet and then we live for 10 minutes
and go back home
isn't that life right now for everyone
that's it you're on for 10 minutes
you're locked up in the hotel
it has been weird though not having
shows at night for me because
you i usually get away with like wasting
the entirety of the morning
it's like yeah the work is at night and
then 8 p.m rolls around you're like
oh i didn't do anything yeah
and then you have to kind of deal with
family and be like oh these people have
dreams as well
and lives that i have missed out on this
entire time but
that's that's been fun other people
other people yeah
are you going crazy a little bit and not
being able to to travel
yeah this is the longest i've been in
one place in
15 years like a decade or 15 years so
it's you know i've gotten to know
my wife again that's been interesting uh
you know
like it's ray did you learn her middle
name yeah
no but we've unlocked like new levels of
fighting which is nice i i feel like
you know normally we'd fight and i'd
have to go like go on the road or
we'd fight and i'd have to go do a thing
now we fight
in this time to plot revenge and [ __ ]
man so it's it's like
it's right yeah okay i'm so glad you
brought this up because i
this has been happening to me i'm locked
out with my girlfriend and i'll notice
that
i'm fighting like just because i have
the time
to fight like before i would just give
up i'm like yeah
i gotta go on the road you win you she's
gonna win anyway so it's just like
yeah end it but now i'm i'm honestly the
other night i was like oh yeah you would
say that you're exactly like your mom
i don't know that to be true at all i'm
just trying to pass a thursday
i think also you you go through like
five reactions to what they say and then
you kind of go
ah covered and then it's done you know
where
yeah we're all saying stuff that we just
like we were fighting the other day and
she was like
you know what burn in hell which is
a very like that's a powerful thing to
say
you know when you're fighting about like
parmesan cheese or something like that
and i was just like
right this is cheese hell okay coped
that's what this is and then you kind of
let that go
but you could just use that as a cop out
for everything just like
it's listen yeah i cheated on you but
you know
covet man i'm gonna milk this thing for
at least three more years
like as long as i i don't care if i'm
freshly vaccinated i'm still milking
this thing yeah
are you doing the like are you doing the
elbow when you meet people are you doing
like distant wave yeah yeah so a couple
of things i'm doing like the
the elbow bumps some people are are
going for handshakes and i'm like no
yeah one guy the other day he was doing
um i was doing this like virtual show
and then he was a guy checking in
anytime he went to go listen he would
pull the mask
off he'd be like so we're just gonna
have you guys come in and out and then
what was that
yeah like he could hear out of his mouth
what are you doing what's
what's the protocol bumps i mean we've
had the namaste for years right
and now there's like american people and
british people doing the namaste and i'm
like no
no you don't get to do it i'm sorry this
is i know there's a pandemic but i
no this is cultural appropriation
absolutely not we're not doing yoga
why people are wanting to do this for so
long like
without signing up for yoga you don't
get to do it no
right bowing can you just bow no
i don't know i feel like that's too much
respect
to show someone like yeah who's the last
person you met and you were like you
know what they deserve a bow
i can't think of like you know this
person is awesome
you know yeah maybe i haven't i haven't
found anyone bow worthy in a very long
time
yeah when the lockdown happened so you
know in
in in india we have you know household
help is a big is a bigger thing in india
right so everybody has like staff
that kind of lives with them in the
house i mean it's
i mean we learned that from from you
guys but you kind of forgot about it
along the way and we just kind of kept
it going
you pay your staff in america we had a
lot of trouble not
paying the people that worked at the
house so then when the lockdown happened
we just
every indian person was like look at me
i'm cleaning my own kitchen and i'm
i'm doing my own dishes and i'm i'm
sweeping my own floor and i'm like
it took a global pandemic to make you
behave like
every european and every american in the
world right now there's
there's nothing special about you doing
dishes quit posting that [ __ ] on
instagram right now
i'm suspicious of people with clean
apartments i think cleaning apartments
should get shut down you see someone
cleaning they're prepping for a party
yeah i think so
i think so they're trying to get people
out is that not allowed over there are
you not allowed to have like gatherings
and like people over is that
not allowed but it's also america so
anything that's the rule people like
what's my right so
there's a lot of states here that have
not locked down at all
like at all for the last six months like
they've locked down but
they've really never locked down like
florida never did a lockdown
well also florida doesn't do a lot of
stuff that america does it's really its
own
i wonder if india has a florida
equivalent is there a state or a region
that people are just like this
is that's everything we're embarrassed
about
the appendix in your body isn't it
florida it's just never worked for
anything
and you haven't been able to don't need
it yeah we don't even know about it
until it becomes a major pain
yeah it could destroy the rest no
no i i think i mean this is
controversial but
we feel about i feel like india and
pakistan feel about each other how you
feel about florida
maybe that's the way that this goes okay
you know
like yes in fact yeah certain regions
can be
the florida like florida is your
pakistan florida is america's pakistan
that should be the flag
that should be the tagline welcome to
florida america's pakistan
i'm sure florida would love the
comparison yeah it is uh we have this
like
idea of of like everyone in india
indian accent at least in media here
that everyone is indian accent
is a genius yeah so anyone that's in a
heist movie which is cool when you were
in the show uh whistle cavalier spy
crime show you're in these like three
piece suits you get to actually kick
ass you're not the guy in the van which
usually you get
type cast yeah cause america's just hear
that like this guy is
genius yeah yeah or he's in the simpsons
but one of the two yeah the thing you
know
the strange thing with that is like i
was thinking about it the other day
uh i don't mind
that accent like you know i i know a lot
of like
indian kids who grew up in america right
and who were like well i got bullied
because of that accent and it propagates
the wrong stereotypes and
and i was called up and sometimes you
know there's a billion of us who just
sit back and go
hey man apoo isn't the indian with the
funny accent
like you are you know like i know a
billion people who sound like a poo
you know and it's not strange to us at
all but on whiskey it was kind of cool
to have an indian character who wasn't
eager to please and have his stuff
together and you know just doing numbers
and this was just a guy who was bad with
people
and and good with guns which you know
some some indians are
i think yeah it's just it's just cool to
see that to go against
not you know see every indian character
through the white perspective of what we
you know stereotyping yeah as i think so
i think so because i really
really liked i think the first thing i
ever saw on you was uh your netflix
special
where right away you go like this this
is my accent and
for once i think i remember the core i
might butcher it but
the indian accent is going to be
perspective and not
yeah i mean that's it's important to me
and also just to show indians as
as flawed people or people who are in
doubt or people who
don't have their entire lives planned
ahead of them i
i would love to see an indian have sex
on american television and this is not
because i i haven't seen an indian have
sex
or i haven't seen american television i
just have seen those two things
like we have a billion people we're
having sex
uh and and yet nobody i've never seen an
indian character hook up
on tv i've never seen that either right
they just don't show it i think this is
you should start doing this i think you
put on unsolicited self
tapes you edit yourself into already
famous sex scenes
yeah you basic instinct yourself right
now
right you're already bottom lips right
now you just go across those legs
just me with like a with a cigarette and
then just two white cops on the other
end
who are being used instead of arresting
me which would be
yeah you know to be applauded as a hero
and a pervert
yeah i think so yeah this is the
direction as your new manager i would
love to
get you on tape and expose well this was
so much fun beer thank you so much for
joining the show it's really nice
talking to you i don't think i ever got
a chance to really talk to you i've seen
all your stuff
and this was this is a lot of fun it was
a lot of fun as well i hope to see you
soon and i
i hope the gigs go well man like like i
hope you enjoy it and just eat it all up
i'm back out there i'm trying to get to
india so
you're if your people want to follow you
and they want to maybe uh if you're
starting this tour up this is happening
in january
in january uh i'm uh dave das on twitter
not because i'm arrogant just vidas
mistaken so i can do that
on instagram and on facebook and yeah
just come see the shows
and there's two or three netflix
specials out there
there are uh three netflix specials out
there um yeah
and they're fun so yeah because you're
at home please check them out
i really recommend them they're they're
really great and people have nothing but
time on their hands
yeah uh thank you so much thank you so
much all right
see you to see you soon all right one
more thing guys before we get out of
here i want to bring on my friend poppy
lou who's been doing some some great
work with reproductive
justice she's an actor and an activist
please welcome poppy hey papi
hi so good of you to take some time out
from your
schedule as a smash hit sitcom star
yeah the cult classic sunny side right
up there with
donnie darko it really is the donnie
darko of sitcoms
you know that's the only way to describe
it
and you are the jake gyllenhaal of
indie comedy is what everyone says i
keep saying that to deadline they keep
sending me the same cease and desist
thank you for being here i wanted to
talk to you because you're doing
something cool
with with this time and uh maybe you
could tell us a little bit about some of
your your activism work you probably
explain it a little bit better
than i can but it's around reproductive
justice which is
a very important issue right now and is
getting even more serious
because of our recent supreme court
whoopsie daisies
yeah um so i serve on the board
of a really incredible organization
called sister song
um sisters and women of color
reproductive justice collective
and it is entirely led by black
indigenous
latinx and asian pacific islander women
of color and queer trans people of color
um with the idea that like we need to be
centering
the most marginalized communities first
if we're trying to
create the liberated world that we are
dreaming of
and the reason why it's reproductive
justice is because
kind of prior to this the movement
around like abortion was very much like
like a white second wave feminist
like um framework of it in terms of
pro-choice and anti-choice
um that's how like abortion was talked
about and that was sort of like the
extent of the conversation
about like body autonomy and rights but
um the idea here is that you know you
don't really have
choice actually if you don't have access
you know you don't have choice if you're
facing state violence
you don't face you don't have choice if
you're undocumented
um and you can't like and you're fearing
deportation you don't have choice if
like
you know you're incarcerated so this
is more about access it's about meeting
communities and people where they're at
um
and it's really shifting the
conversation into a way that's looking
more holistically at
um sister sung says it's really great
they're like it's about people's
rights that have children if they want
to not have children if they don't want
to
and to raise their families in safe and
sustainable environments
that's the organization they're the best
they're so great more recently during
quarantine
i started a campaign within sister song
called asians for black births which is
in support of the work that deputy
director leah jones
um at sister song is doing that's called
the birth justice care fund which is
just
like providing direct funds for right
now
like um primarily black mamas and
caregivers in georgia
um just support around birth postpartum
labor doula needs like midwives etc
and so this campaign asians for black
births
is like really rallying my asian
american and asian pacific islander
communities
to be supporting this work um and it's
not just a fundraiser we're hoping that
like we're using this to like
actually kind of share information with
asian american communities
who like historically have been very
complicit with whiteness have really not
examined their own
proximity to whiteness um have like not
always shown solidarity with black and
brown communities
um and like really asking ourselves
during this moment to be like we need to
look at
our own histories our own complicities
to understand how we show up as like
migrants
at like in this moment in time okay so
as far as the the organization goes
it's it's helping people with with
actual resources or some of the money is
going towards
sometimes just supporting some of these
yeah
so the birth justice care fund is direct
monetary support for people that are
giving birth
um but sister song at large they do all
sorts of things
um including uh court cases
well you're doing really great work and
you're honestly making us
look bad for not doing the same so
people want to support
sister song and the work you're doing
which you've already raised
a lot of money where can people find you
if they want to
they want to help out for asians for
black birth you can go to
at asians for blackbirds on instagram
and then there's a link that goes to the
gofundme and yeah learn more about
sister song they're on instagram
at sister song underscore woc um
and sisterzone.net so go there
until everything we're there okay thank
you so much for talking with us
and and educating us and letting us know
what we can do to help because there's
honestly so many things out there that
just to narrow it down is great have you
noticed this
thank you love you too thank you so much
good seeing you poppy lou everyone the
organization is sister song
that's gonna do it for us we appreciate
you guys joining us for the show huge
thank you to fema anwar
beerdas and of course poppy liu thank
you we'll see you soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's the music in your soul
just need to
each other's lose
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if yes surrender
just get by
where are you doing
keep on shining
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
just